make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and uh
make sure you guys hit the like button
if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back again with dc's dark crisis
except now that we're done with justice
league frontier now we're focusing on
justice league incarnate this is the
multiversal justice league team and so
this is actually going to connect the
dots between what we saw in the last
story that we covered and what goes on
in the future of the dark crisis event
and so what this does here is this
initially picks up on earth eight now
earth aid is a world that we don't
really know a whole lot about we don't
know much about that universe but we do
know it's the universe that machine head
had come from remembering that machine
head was part of justice incarnate he
was part of the multiversal justice
league team that remembering that
machine head was one of a multitude of
people out there who was one part of the
justice league incarnate but two and
more significantly as far as these other
people were concerned had actually
joined the cause of darkseid the idea of
dark side being that he could basically
create a crack in the multiverse using
barry allen and then harness the power
of the great darkness and use it to
recreate the multiverse in his own image
and that those individuals who allied
themselves with darkseid would basically
be in a position to where their
universes would be safe now of course
they don't truly know darkseid and
they're kind of fools for believing that
would be the case but the thing about
this is that on earth eight we end up
getting met by the arrival of dr
multiverse who's a new character being
introduced here and in fact dr
multiverse is a person that is totally
mistrusted by her team right by the
retaliators now she was part of the team
at one point but was actually kicked off
now this is one of those things where we
can kind of read between the cracks here
in terms of what's going on no pun
intended but what's going on with her
character that the way that the power of
dr multiverse works is that dr
multiverse has what is essentially
cosmic awareness but it's cosmic
awareness in terms of how she sees
things so she basically sees herself in
the greater multiverse and where she
resides so she can literally look at a
person and see every version of
themselves across the multiverse and
we'll actually see how that manifests
here in a little while the kicker about
all this is that because she's so
powerful and because she represents such
a much larger landscape in relation to
everything else that ultimately people
hate her because she reminds them of
just how small they really are that in
truth their lives don't really amount to
anything in relation to the existence of
the greater multiverse itself and as a
result of that she was actually kicked
off of her own superhero team but as we
saw at the end of the last video that
basically machine head had essentially
been destroyed by dark side but dr
multiverse had found his head just kind
of floating out there in the multiverse
bouncing between universes and what this
meant is that when she discovered it she
realized there's something going on out
there in the greater multiverse that the
multiverse is essentially broken now we
don't know how much of this she's aware
of in relation to everything because
even we don't necessarily know
everything that's going on we will we'll
find out the greater things that are
going on here but in the midst of
everything that's happening suddenly the
forces of the retaliators are attacked
by tartarus now tartarus is really
interesting here because he's gonna turn
out to be dc's version of thanos but
what we end up doing is switching over
to earth zero in beijing and we actually
pick up with avery who's basically the
flash of china now if those guys who
aren't familiar with her we're not gonna
go into a full in-depth character
explanation here about her but avery is
basically one of the individuals who is
an aftermath of the of the the original
flash story that was done during rebirth
where basically you had the the flash
storm right the speed force storm that
granted the speed force to a whole bunch
of different people one of whom was like
godspeed and so on and so forth that
when it comes to avery she was a girl
who gained the abilities of the flash
albeit not necessarily on the same level
of power as barry allen and that she
operates as the flash in china and so as
she's here and facing off against
replicant who basically has the
intention of destabilizing the banks of
china and then forcing the world to rely
on cryptocurrency and that lux coin will
go to the moon
um that what it does is of course leads
her to kind of stepping in and
intervening and so on and so forth but
in the midst of all this what you have
is uh thomas wayne from the flashpoint
universe and you've got president
superman both of whom are part of
justice incarnate who are watching this
girl in action and once she's done they
actually jump in and they effectively
tell her we need your speedster powers
and it's really kind of a cool
explanation that's given here because
one of the things that happens is where
she's a little uncertain about what's
going on they open a boom tube and she's
like is that a boom tube i'm 100 in and
then just leaps in and just jumps in but
once everything kind of clears and she
gets back to a state of normalcy you get
this cool explanation and it's a really
great way for joshua williamson to
basically tell us hey so like here's
everything that's going on uh in case
you missed it which i think is a great
little telltale here and what this means
is that for the most part we're kind of
given a refresher over justice for uh
justice league frontier but for those of
you guys who are still a little murky
even after after the ending of that
story all they really know and really
the way it's explained here is it said
the multiverse has a problem which means
justice league incarnate has a problem
that darkseid the god of everything evil
manipulated barry allen to crack the
multiverse itself so that he could steal
whatever power was on the other side and
basically end everything as they know it
but barry's speed forced him to be
trapped on the other side which now we
know is multiverse too it's the
multiverse that existed before the
original crisis on infinite earth's
event that where we originally thought
that multiverse was destroyed then in
fact it wasn't that multiverse is still
very much there and so what they need is
avery to be able to tap into the speed
force to use her powers to rescue barry
allen and then close the crack and the
multiverse thereby preventing darkseid
from being able to access what's on the
other side or prevent whatever's on the
other side from entering into multiverse
one right entering into their multiverse
and so that's one of the things to know
here everybody here none of them know
that there's multiverse two on the other
side none of them are aware of that all
they know is that there's just a source
of energy on the other side the dark
side was trying to get his hands on and
because it's dark side this is a bad
thing so they just need to close the
close the crack and that's it they have
no clue what's there and so what they've
done is they've basically developed
what's called the quantum treadmill
which basically would allow avery to use
her speed force powers to essentially
allow justice incarnate to travel to the
other side of inyo into multiverse 2 and
then grab barry and bring him back the
issue with this is that avery doesn't
really believe that she can pull this
off and in fact she doesn't even really
know why she's here and the reality of
this is that barry allen had appointed
avery as one the flash and two avery was
gonna be his replacement should anything
happen right should anything happen to
him that she's the one that's going to
take his place and by extension the
justice league incarnates see her as the
replacement barry allen now it's not
really joshua williamson saying like
she's better than wally west or anything
like that right like hardcore fans will
take that as what is it meaning that
that's not what it means before you
freak out
they have their own stories going on in
their own sets of events honestly she's
playing this role because in truth there
really isn't anybody else but of course
using the treadmill for the first time
and not knowing exactly what it is she's
doing she transports them all to earth
eight when they get there they end up
finding earth eight is already in a
state of shambles the tartarus has
already attacked new york he's already
just obliterated most of the retaliators
and in fact those individuals who remain
are not at all happy in seeing the
justice league incarnate because
remember one of the big talking points
that was revealed to us during the
justice league frontier storyline is
that what you have is you have all these
events that happen on a multiversal
level the original crisis on defenders
the infinite crisis event final crisis
zero hour crisis in time the flashpoint
event new 52 all that kind of stuff
right dr manhattan that there have
always been these massive crisis events
that affect the entire multiverse and
that the stories that we've seen have
focused on how the earth zero heroes
have been able to like overcome this
threat and save the day but we never
really got to see the other side of the
equation which is the planets that are
caught in collateral damage the
alternate universes that are caught in
collateral damage with regards to this
whole conflict and that's how you ended
up with groups like the retaliators
people on other earth who are aware of
the multiverse they know more about the
multiverse than any of the superheroes
on earth zero do but they hate earth
zero and they don't want to be a part of
the multiverse they would remove
themselves from it if they could because
every single time there's some kind of a
multiversal collapse or multiversal
event they get caught in the crossfire
and so that's why they're not happy to
see these guys and so in fact when the
justice league incarnate is here that
one of the things is revealed is that
the retaliators knew exactly what
machine had done that they they were
talking about how they were aware of
whose psycho pirate was and in fact the
entire group of superheroes here
basically voted and that machine head
was their emissary essentially but they
were all on board with working with
darkseid to basically allow darkseid to
achieve his goal and to protect their
universe in the multiverse which
astonishes the entirety of justice
league incarnate right they're like we
all knew we voted to take the deal our
world has been attacked by the
multiverses too many times and so
ultimately psychopirate was being
controlled by darkseid and that they
were being lied to but they didn't care
because in the end the ends justified
the means before they can continue any
further tartarus makes his move and
starts attacking everybody yet again and
then bringing all of his forces to bear
now of course the crack as it exists
here is one of those things where it's a
little ambiguous the crack is presented
to us as being as much of a physical
object as it is something that's
happening and the reason why i say this
is because there's a point when tartarus
is talking to everybody there and
basically in saying that like they're
they're a lost cause here there's no way
they can overcome them yada yada you
have no hope of defeating me and then
darkseid emerges and said hope is not
required only darkseid and so what he
says is he literally tells him like give
me your piece of the crack and that's
one of the things that's a little
strange here is joshua williamson
doesn't do the best job explaining
exactly how this works is the crack part
and parcel to tartarus right it's the
thing that's basically that that he kind
of harbors a portion of its energy and
by stripping that energy away from
tartarus what it does is it allows
darkseid to get closer to being able to
open the crack on his own is the crack
of physical object that tartarus carries
around that williamson and even just dc
as a whole doesn't do a good job of
explaining that and they never do
they're never good at explaining that
it's always one of those things where
they treat it as a kind of physical
slash meta textual thing it's one of the
most frustrating things about when dc
creates crisis events the meta textual
stuff with the way that everything is
written on this broad scale level
honestly it can make it a pain in the
ass but the thing about this and really
what happens here is you basically end
up finding out that somewhere along the
line before all the different iterations
of dark side across really across like
the the various universes before they
had all merged into like true form dark
side as we like to call them at the
moment before that it happened that
there was a point when you ended up
having tartarus who had made a deal with
one of the versions of darkseid and that
version of darkseid would leave tartarus
alone he would allow him to just kind of
conquer his own universe and call it a
day it was a you stay away i stay away
kind of thing but now that all the
different forms of dark side are
consolidated into one being the response
to dark side is i recognize no such
treaty right give me your portion of the
crack of the the crack in the multiverse
or or like i'm just going to annihilate
you and we're going to call it a day
right like that kind of a thing what
this does is it leads to a fight
breaking out between the two of them but
this also gives us a few more
indications of the nature of dr
multiverse's power when she looks at
darkseid and realizes the dark side is
quite literally the only version of
himself across the multiverse there are
no universe versions of darkseid that's
it he's unto himself in the same way
that dr multiverse is there's only one
of her so in a lot of ways she's kind of
a stand-in for captain universe in
marvel comics if captain universe
operated on a multiversal level which
captain universe technically doesn't do
there's a captain universe in every
single universe but she's kind of that
that sort of character the other reason
why tartarus is being viewed here is
like dc's version of thanos is because
much like thanos harnessing the power of
the infinity stones which grant
limitless energy that what ended up
happening here is along the lines
tartarus had harnessed like the entirety
of the emotional spectrum and is
literally using all the lantern rings
unto himself so it's kind of treated as
infinity stones to a degree right in the
sense that like they harness different
aspects of the universe because it's not
one of those things where he's
harnessing like hope and love and so on
and so forth the rings of the ancient
spectrum here are sources of energy
they're sources of power as opposed to
simply just tapping into the emotional
spectrum and calling it a day and so
while these guys basically break down
into an actual fight between each other
literally tartar is trying to destroy
dark side so we can continue his quest
to conquer his universe and in fact
spread his influence out into the
multiverse dark side trying to stop him
from doing that so he can basically
conquer the multiverse the way you end
up having is the justice league
incarnate that actually tries to find a
way to take this portion of the crack
that dark side has because they can't
keep it from him themselves that if they
take it to their base of operations
darkseid will find them and take it back
the only real way to seemingly keep it
safe is to get it lost in the multiverse
somewhere to where darkseid simply won't
be able to find it or to put it
somewhere he can't get it across the
multiverse that before they can do that
that the crack actually takes off into
the multiverse itself that it literally
just kind of disappears now dr
multiverse for her part ends up creating
a portal using the energy of avery of
the flash to basically create rifts in
the dimensional barriers between
universes she literally creates a portal
and then tells them you have to go out
and you have to find that crack and you
have to do something with it but what
this does is it basically turns the
story essentially into a cat and mouse
game that in their efforts to find this
crack and find out what's behind all of
this that what it's actually going to do
is just kind of send them jumping into
different alternate realities in these
various stories and in fact give us
different depictions of characters
across the multiverse so what this is in
a lot of ways those guys those are guys
coming from marvel comics in a lot of
ways what this is is a blend between
what jonathan hickman did with avengers
and new avengers going into secret wars
and a traditional crisis event from dc
comics it's pretty genius it's a very
smart move and it's a it's a great way
to blend these two things that we would
normally see as being separate and bring
them together and make them similar and
so what this does is it leads to dr
multiverse grabbing uh grabbing avery
who doesn't really see herself as being
ready for any of this right she offers a
kind of personal speech where she's like
you know i had great power thrust upon
me at 1.2 and that kind of a thing which
is cool because it creates a bit of a
bond between the two but i don't think
anybody really cares about some
impassioned speech made between two
characters who were like you got to
learn to trust yourself bro like so what
is what they end up doing
is they basically jump into the
multiverse and they end up disappearing
from the purview of the rest of the
justice incarnate because they don't
know where they're going they have no
clue where it is they're heading to now
of course we'll end up following their
story later but in the midst of all this
the entirety of justice incarnate is met
by the arrival of orion now of course
orion is the actual son of dark side but
is trying to work to destroy dark side
and that's usually how that works what
joshua williamson doing here is he's
really kind of pulling the traditional
strings of a multiversal event right
things that we're the most familiar with
that darkseid has a son named orion who
lives on on a new genesis with high
father and high father has a son named
scott free who lives in apocalypse with
darkseid like it was a kind of switching
of the sons to broker a truce because
neither wanted to see their son
destroyed uh and that orion usually
works to try to defeat darkseid because
he was raised to believe that darkseid
was evil that kind of a thing and so him
being here is quite literally i'm the
only one here that can defeat darkseid
and the only way to really make this
work right the only way to save the
multiverse is to make it bleed is to
essentially try to destroy it and then
kill darkseid in that way because dark
side exists across the multiverse
eradicating the multiverse means
eradicating him so basically doing it
but by a different means or for a
different purpose that kind of seems to
be the case but the forces of dark side
with all these parademons led by
calaback led by his i guess kind of
other son this leads to them invading
justice incarnate so obviously looking
at this first issue it's gonna have like
some cool moments of the story and it's
gonna have some moments we don't care
about i imagine that the whole instance
of like following the entirety of
justice incarnate and uh literally their
story across the multiverse that's
probably the more interesting part i
don't know if you guys really care about
the headquarters being attacked by the
forces of darkseid i don't know if that
really matters to you but thank you all
for watching and i will catch you all
next week where we continue on our
journey to watch the dark side get
destroyed and dc launch yet another
crisis to fix the last crisis they just
launched which was designed to fix all
the other crisis events they had before
the nature of dc comics thank you guys
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace